ANOTHER ONE POTENTIALLY TO
HEARINGS THIS WEEK AS THERE ARE
SOME CAN BILLS THAT ARE
CONTINUE TO MOVE. TOWARDS THE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE WE HAVE TO AUTHORS
WHO ARE HERE TODAY WE'RE GONNA
START WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK WE'RE GRATEFUL IS HERE
HE'S CAN BE PRESENTING AN A. B.
SEVEN TWENTY THREE WERE THEN
GOING TO TURN IT OVER TO THE
GRAYSON SHOW ON A. B. SEVEN
FIVE FOR ANY FOURTEEN EIGHTY
THREE B. WE'RE GONNA START THE
COMMITTEE AS A SUB THIS
MORNING. IT WILL ADD ON HIS WE
ESTABLISH A QUORUM OF THE VICE
CHAIR WHICH HE IS HERE LEGALLY
FOR EVERY MEETING WE COULD NOT
BE MORE GRATEFUL IS UNABLE TO
MAKE IT TODAY AND HAD A
CONVERSATION WITH THEM AND IT
IS SIXTIES UP THE SAME THAT
MISTER MOORE WALKING JUST WANNA
SAY THANK YOU TO HIM. OUT FOR
ALL OF HIS WORK ON BEHALF OF
THE COMMITTEE WE'RE GONNA TURN
IT OVER TO MR QUIRK ON A. B.
SEVEN TWENTY THREE FOCUS ON
ALAMEDA AND CREWS. COUNTIES.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS SIR AND GOOD
MORNING. GOOD MORNING. MICRON'S
WORKING OF THANK YOU CHAIR AND
SENATOR I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR THE
GREAT WORK THEY'VE DONE QUICKLY
AND RISING THIS BILL I'M
PRESENTING A. B. SEVEN TO THREE
AGAIN AFTER MAKING SOME CHANGES
TO THE BILL THAT THE NEWSOME
ADMINISTRATION HELPED US WITH
AB SEVEN TWENTY THREE MAKES
CHANGES TO HOW THE TRANSACTION
AND USE TAX LAW CAP IS
CALCULATED FOR ALAMEDA AND
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY. SOME
COUNTIES ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
PROVIDING A WIDE RANGE SUPPORT
SERVICES. SUCH AS SHELTERS FOR
THE HOMELESS POLICE AND FIRE
SERVICES. THE CHANGE IN AB
SEVEN TWENTY THREE WILL GIVE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS NEEDED
FLEXIBILITY AND THE OPTION TO
OBTAIN ADDITIONAL REVENUE TO
PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED GENERAL
PURPOSE. LOCAL GOVERNMENT
SERVICES SUCH AS ROAD REPAIRS
PARK MAINTENANCE AND
HOMELESSNESS SHELTERS WITH ME
TODAY IS NICOLO. DELUCA FROM
THE CITY OF FREMONT
REPRESENTING THE CITY OF
FREMONT AND MONICA MILLER WITH
THE COUNTY OF ALAMEDA. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WE HAVE A GREAT
LAW FIRM A DELUCA AND MILLER
HERE IN FRONT OF US I WOULD
LIKE TO GO TO SEE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO BE A KICK **** OFF IT'S
GOING TO BE MILLER AT THE FLOOR
IS YOURS MANY OF TWO MINUTES
AND QSL ADD MISTER CHAIR.
SENATOR THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HAVING US HERE THIS MORNING WE
APPRECIATE YOUR STOCKS WORK AS
WELL AS THE ASEMBLY MEMBER AND
HIS STAFF WORK IN THE NEWS THE
MINISTRATION AND WORKING THIS
OUT. SO SEVEN TWENTY THREE
SIMPLY JUST ALLOWS FOR THE
LOCAL VOTERS TO DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT THEY WANT TO
INCREASE THEIR SALES TAX
THROUGH ITS ITS LOCALLY VOTED
UPON THEY CAN DENY IT THEY CAN
INCREASE SAID IT'S UP TO THEM.
ON CURRENTLY WE'RE LOOKING AT
IN MARCH OF INCREASING POINT 5%
WHICH WE ALREADY HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO DO. SENATOR YOUR
AVAILABLE FROM A FEW YEARS AGO
I'M GONNA USE THAT EARMARKED
SPECIFICALLY FOR CHILDCARE WE
ARE HOPING TO USE THIS
ADDITIONAL PERCENTAGE OF POINT
FIVE FOR OUR HOMELESSNESS ON
THE BALLOT. CRISIS WHICH- ARE
POINT. CAN'T FOUR. PERCENT.
ANIMAL IS TRYING TO ENSURE THAT
WE HAVE ALL THE TOOLS ARE.
BOUGHT BY MANY DIFFERENT PIECE
OF LEGISLATION WORKING. IN
ADMINISTRATION AND BUT- I AM.
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
EMBEDDED FUND BUDGET ITEMS AND
DOLLARS EXCITER AYE TO ENSURE
THAT WE CAN. APPROPRIATELY CARE
FOR OUR HOMELESS POPULATION AND
THIS. PARTICULAR POINT FIVE
PERCENT. WOULD TAKE CARE OF
THAT THE GOAL IS TO ALLOW THEM
TO TAKE CARE OF THOSE THAT ARE.
JUST ON THE EDGE OF BECOMING
HOMELESS. WE WANT TO TRY AND
KEEP THEM. HOUSE SHELTERED
EXTRATERRESTRIAL TODAY WE ARE
DRIVE OUT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. TO DELIVER MISTER
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE NICOLO DELUCA HERE WE
HAVE THE CITY OF FREMONT CITY
OF EMERYVILLE. FIRST REALLY
WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK IN HIS STAFF FOR ALL
THEIR WORK YOUR STAFF FOR ALL
THEIR WORK. THE GOVERNOR'S
ADMINISTRATION FOR ALL THEIR
HELP JUST LIKE WHAT A. STORY
SHEPHERD AND REBUILT FREMONT IF
APPROVED BY THE VOTE. WRITER
TRUCK. PLEASE ADVANCE THIS TIME.
LAST CALL HEARING SEE NINE
WE'RE GONNA TURN IT OVER TO
MISTER WOLF FOR OPPOSITION
TWELVE GOOD MORNING MORNING SIR
IS TO OFFER A SINNER WINNERS
REALLY EXCITED TO BE HERE AT HE
SHARED HIS EXCITEMENT
YESTERDAY. RIGHT BEFORE WE LEFT.
EXACTLY. A REFERENCE MORE LIKE
IS LEARNING GOING TO BE HERE
TODAY. A. COOL GOOD MORNING I
HA I HOPE APPRECIATION IT'S
GREAT. SENATOR YOUR DAD YOUR
ENTHUSIASM WITH MY OPPOSITION.
YEAH MEMBERS GOOD MORNING DAVID
WILL FOR THE HER JARVIS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION TO AB SEVEN TWENTY
THREE MEMBERS ARE POSITION TO
SALES TAX AUTHORIZATION BILLS
ARE PRETTY TYPICAL WE'VE
OPPOSED OTHER SOMEWHERE TAX
AUTHORIZATION BILLS OVER THE
LAST DECADE SALES TAXES ARE
ESPECIALLY REGRESSIVE INTENDED
DISPROPORTIONAL INCREASE
EXPENDITURES FOR LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS IN CONSIDERING THAT
70% OF THE NATION'S ECONOMIC
OUTPUT COMES FROM. THE BUYING
AND SELLING OF DO YOU THINK WE
SHOULD BE CAREFUL BEFORE THE
BUDGET BEFORE YOU KNOW
COMMUNITIES COME TO THE
LEGISLATURE AUTHORIZING
ADDITIONAL SALES TAX INCREASES.
IMPROVE EVEN MORE TAXES SO FOR
THAT A SIGNATURE WERE OPPOSED
WERE ALSO MEMBERS TROUBLED
TODAY BY THE INCLUSION OF SANTA
CRUZ METROPOLITAN TRANSIT
DISTRICT INTO THE BILL. IT
SEEMS LIKE IN MEMBERS I COULD
BE READING THIS PROVISION WRONG
BUT THE DISTRICT APPEARS TO BE
EXEMPTING THEMSELVES FROM THE
BRADLEY BURNS 2% SALES CAP
ENTIRELY NOT JUST PROSPECTIVELY
FOR FUTURE TAXES BUT ALSO
RETROACTIVELY FOR SAY TAXES
ALREADY APPROVED. I DON'T KNOW
IF THAT'S ACCURATE MR OR
PERHAPS YOU ARE THE AUTHOR CAN
SPEAK TO THAT IN A CLUB THOSE
AND IF THAT'S- TRUE WE SEE NO
JUSTIFICATION FOR THIS BECAUSE
IT DIMINISHES LOCAL AGENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY. AND MAKES IT
LIKELY THAT EVEN MORE
AGGRESSIVE TAXES WILL BE PLACED
ON THE BALLOT. AND TAXES THAT
HAVE ALREADY BEEN MOVED. CAT
BEING IT TO GO BACK IN EXEMPTS
THAT 2% AND PRETEND LIKE THIS
TAXES DIDN'T EXIST DOESN'T SEEM
REAL GOOD FOR VOTER APPROVAL.
SOME WOULD ASK FOR NOVA. TOO
MUCH IS A WILL FIVE THREE SHE
DID AND TRYING TO BE
DISRESPECTFUL IN YOUR TESTIMONY
WERE JUST CHECKING IN ON THAT
IN NOT WILL GET BACK TO YOU IN
JUST ONE MOMENT ON THAT WE'D
LIKE TO GET OPENING UP. TO
ANYONE ELSE WHO IS AN OPTION OF
THE BILL. PLEASE IT. IS AT THIS
TIME. LAST CALL FOR OPPOSITION.
BRING TO BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE WANT TO MAKE SURE.
THAT WE ANSWER WERE MISTER
WILSON CONCERN WAS IS. THANKS
TO THE- RESEARCH OF MR NOW TO
MY LEFT. LA MONTEREY CONTRA
COSTA. IN SAN MATTEO COUNTIES
ALSO HAVE THE SAME. AUTHORITY I
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERN REGRETS
ABOUT THE BIRDS THOUGH SO I
KNOW THAT. MAY NOT MAKE IT. IN
YOUR EYES RIGHT BUT I'M SAYING
THE IT IS. OFTEN EASIER.
PREVIOUS SUPPORTED. MR TERM
JUST DECLARE. I'M NOT SURE
THERE IS INSTANCES WERE
RETROACTIVE. CELL I MEAN AND A
AND A NOTE. WE DO THIS ALL THE
TIME RIGHT RE INCREASE SALES
TAX AUTHORIZATIONS ALL THE TIME
FOR FUTURE PERSPECTIVE TAXES
THAT ARE GONNA BE ON THE
BALLOT. CELL AND ANY WE WOULD
STILL BE OPPOSED TO THAT BUT
THIS IS THE FIRST I PERSONALLY
SEEN A RETROACTIVE. SORT OF
EXEMPTION OF A DISTRICT YOU
KNOW AGAINST THE 2% CASH NOW
YOU ARE CORRECTED THEY'RE NOT
RETROACTIVE SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH. SHOULD THAT COMMISSION.
TURN THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE. IF YOU HAVE
ANY. BE ABLE TO ADDRESS AND OR
A CLOSING STATEMENT. ARM AS HE
SAID WHEN I WAS HERE BEFORE I
DON'T THINK WE SHOULD BE
TELLING LOCALS WHAT THEY CAN DO
WITH THEIR SALES TAX AND- THEN
THE- NEWSOME ADMINISTRATION
DECIDED RATHER THAN REYES. CAP
WE SHOULD NOT COUNT SOME OF
THESE REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
AREAS THAT'S HIS CHOICE MINE
WOULD BE JUST TO GET RID OF THE
CAP ALTOGETHER THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER SOLOMON
WHERE WE ARE SO GREAT THAT
YOU'RE HERE I WOULD HAVE TO BE
TO SEE IF ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
THIS. HEARING SEEN NINE IS THE
NUMBER WE DO NOT PERMITTED. WE
WILL TAKE THIS UP AS SOON AS WE
HAVE A FOURTH MEMBER. ANY FINAL
COMMENTS OR CLOSING STATEMENT
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
SOME MEMBER THANK YOU FOR
WORKING WITH US AND FOR YOUR
WORK ON THIS ISSUE AS WELL.
WELL I APPRECIATE IT SO I
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE LETTING US. NOW THEY
WILL THE BILL FORMULATED. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. I THINK GENERAL WE
ARE NOW GOING TO TURN OVER THE
GRAYSON SHOW WE'VE TWO BILLS A.
B. SEVEN FIVE FOUR IN AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE S. AND
LIMBER YOU. HAVE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT ON EACH OF THE BILLS.
THEY WERE GONNA ASK FOR
TRUNCATED VERSION ON SEVEN
FIFTY FOUR AND FOURTEEN EIGHTY
THREE IN REGARDS YOUR
STATEMENT. THE FLOOR IS YOURS
AND WE ALWAYS ENJOY A MISTER
GRAYSON IN PRETTY WELCOME SIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. HONORED BE
BEFORE YOU TODAY. FIRST I WANT
TO SAY I'VE ALREADY REQUESTED A
RULE WAIVER TO INCORPORATE THE
CHANGES DESCRIBED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. AB SEVEN
FIFTY FOUR WILL ENABLE EIGHT
ONE ONE CENTERS TO FULFILL
THEIR STATUTORY A STATUTORILY.
MANDATED DUTY TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S INFRASTRUCTURE
SIMPLY BY PUTTING ON THE
APPLICATION FOR PERMITS. THAT
THEY ARE REQUIRED TO CONTACT.
EIGHT ONE ONE. BEFORE THEY DAY.
THE BILL WILL REQUIRE THE
OFFICE OF PLANNING RESOURCES AT
A REFERENCE TO HIS CALIFORNIA
SOLAR PERMITTING GUIDE BOOK.
REGARDING THIS REQUIREMENT. AND
THE BILL PROVIDE NO CITY OR
COUNTY WILL BE LIABLE FOR SOME
FAILURE TO NOTIFY. THE
REGIONAL. CONSIDER UP INTO THE
SKY. I DO HAVE A WITNESS SAID
MR CAN COST THAT. DAY FOR
ENERGY. THANK YOU SO MUCH CAN
FISH IN IN HERE AND THEN ALSO
ARE I. KNOW YOU GET INTO IS
THIS COMES OFF OFA TRAGEDY
THAT A SIDE AT SOME PRIDE IN
APPRECIATE THAT THE
COORDINATION WITH THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ON THIS THE NUMBER YOU
TAKE THE LEAD IN REGARD TO TURN
THAT TRAGEDY INTO. POLICY THAT
DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN THE FLOOR
IS YOURS SIR YES YOU CAN'T
CAL'S WITH SAN DIEGO GAS
ELECTRIC AND SO CAL GAS WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR AND STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THIS AS YOU
NOTE ON JULY FIFTEENTH WE HAD
WE LOST AN EMPLOYEE AND A CITY
OF MARIETTA. WHO IS RESPONDING
TO REPORTS OF A GAS LEAK OF THE
GAS LEAK WAS CAUSED BY THE
INSERTION OF A GROUNDING ROD
INTO THE GROUND IT IS UNCOMMON
FOR SOLAR HELPERS TO USE CAR
RIDES WHERE THEY DON'T ALWAYS
USE THEM. I SHOULD SAY SO THIS
AT NELSON. EDUCATION BUILT TO
SPILL THANK NOTED BY THE
AUTHOR. I WOULD THINK THIS
COULD HELP EDUCATE FOLKS THE
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE BOARD
ALREADY HAS SOME EDUCATION
EFFORTS. WE THINK JUST A COUPLE
OF SIMPLE STEPS WERE ALSO
TALKING TO THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION THEY HAVE A SIMILAR.
GUIDEBOOK FOR SOLAR INSTALLS TO
ADD A NOTATION THIS. OF EFFORT.
WE ALSO APPRECIATE CENTER HILL
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN HE
APPROVED HE GOT A BILL THROUGH
SB SIX SIX ONE. AND IN THAT
BILL IT TALKED A LOT ABOUT
EDUCATION AND THE EDUCATION
NEEDS AND IT HAS THE NEW DIG
BOARD THAT WAS CREATED BY THAT
BILL. IDENTIFYING NEW EDUCATION
OUTREACH EFFORTS THATWOULD BE
HELPFUL WE HAPPENED AS A RESULT
OF THIS TRAGEDY TO IDENTIFY ONE
AND APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR AND
COMMITTEE FOR. PURSUING THIS
BILL MASS FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR GOOD
MORNING. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR ROB CHRIS BECAUSE OUR
BEHALF OF USA NORTH. ONE WHERE
THE IN NORTHERN CALL CENTER
THAT IT'S A NOT FOR PROFIT
DEDICATED TO EXPIRATION SAFETY
WE'RE PROUD TO BE HEADQUARTERED
IN THE SOME MEMBERS DISTRICT.
AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS WE SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
LAYS IN GERMANY COULD CENTER
FOR SURVEYS HERE AND READY TO
ROLL. WE ARE GONNA OPEN UP TO
ANYONE ELSE WHO IS IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL IF YOU COULD PLEASE
ADVANCE IN THIS AT THIS TIME.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR THOSE IN
SUPPORT. LAST CALL. WE'RE NOT
GONNA ASK FOR THOSE WHO MAY BE
OPPOSE. IN PROPOSITION. WE'RE
GONNA BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE. MR SOMEONE WOULD YOU
MIND IF WE SO WISH QUORUM.
PLEASE ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO
MUCH LAYS IN GENERAL RECEPTION
FORM THANK JUST A RECALL PLEASE.
HERE WHERE PRESENT MORLOCK
THEY'LL- THEY'LL PRESENT
HERTZBERG HER CODDLE. NIELSEN
NIELSEN PRESIDENT WIENER.
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN ESTABLISH BY
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU MISS
LANE CHESTER WOULD LIKELY TO
SEE IF WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE ON THIS
ISSUE. WE ALSO WELCOME THE
MOTION AT THIS TIME. AWKWARD
SILENCE. AND THE MOTION SO WE
DO HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR
BY SENATOR BAIL MISTER GRAYSON
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE SIMPLY
AND RESPECT FOR NAY VOTE GOOD
TIMES ALRIGHT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE POTION IS
RETURNED THE BILL TO THE SENATE
FLOOR MISS LANCHESTER CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. HI
WARLOCK SPELL STILL I HERTZBERG
FURTADO NIELSEN NIELSEN AYE
WIENER WIENER AYE. THE DEBATE
CHEN METAPHORS HERE ABOUT SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH. DO
APPRECIATE IT. YES A MISTER
SOLOMON DO YOU MIND IF WE HAD
BACK IN SUPPORT REPORT HE'S ALL
RIGHT. THE LADY DON'T BE TAKEN
OF AB SEVEN TWENTY THREE THIS
IS ITEM ONE ON OUR DOCKET BY
SOME MEMBER QUIRK IS THERE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR. HEY WE GOT
A MOTION WE GET A MOTION BY THE
GOOD CENTER FROM SAN JOSE THE
MOTIONS RETURN THE BILL TO THE
SENATE FLOOR. MESSENGERS AGAIN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. HI I'M
MORE LOG. I HERTZBERG RICARDO.
YELTSIN YELTSIN NO WINNER
WIENER THAT IS A THREE ONE
WE'RE GONNA KEEP THAT BILL ON
CALL LEASING GERMAN THIS IS OUR
THIRD AND FINAL ITEM OF THE DAY
THIS IS A BE FOURTEEN EIGHTY
THREE. I WILL. NOT PUT WORDS
INTO THE MOUTH OF THE SIMILAR
OVER THIS IS AN ISSUE BY THAT
DECEMBER HAS REALLY BEEN
FOCUSING ON APPRECIATE THE WORK
ON THAT. ALSO APPRECIATE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. HE HE CAME TO
US EARLIER IN THE YEAR WANTED
US TO BE ABLE TO MOVE THE BILL
WHICH WE DID AND KEPT HIS WORD
OF SAYING THAT HEY LOOK ONE OF
YOU TO COME BACK AND REALLY
WORK ON THIS ITEM. AGAIN TURN
YOUR MASTER BUT I THINK THIS IS
ONE OF TWO MAYBE A FEW THAT YOU
CAN WE TAKE A LOOK AT AN ALL
ISSUES THE FEES AND APPRECIATE
WORK ON THE SERVER. THEFLOOR
IS YOURS AND IT'S ONE EIGHT
KNOWLEDGE THE CHAIR WOMAN AS
THE AGUIAR-CURRY WITHIN WORKING
IN COLLABORATION WITH AS WELL.
WORK ON THAT ALONG WITH MR
GRAYSON FORESHORES. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AND I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT A.
B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE I
WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY THANKING
THE CHAIR HAS BEEN A TREMENDOUS
HELP AND THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT AS WELL FOR THEIR
WORK IN CRAFTING THE AMENDMENTS
TO THIS BILL. THIS YEAR UC
BERKELEY'S TURNER CENTER
DELIVERED A REPORT ON THE
AFFECT THE REST OF RESIDENTIAL
IMPACT FEES AND WHAT THE AFFECT
HAS ON HOUSING PRODUCTION IN
CALIFORNIA ONE OF THE REPORTS
WILL REPORTS KEY FINDINGS WAS
THAT DEVELOPMENT FEE SCHEDULES
ARE OFTEN UNCLEAR AND DIFFICULT
TO FIND THE REPORT NOTED THAT A
LACK OF TRANSIENT TRANSPARENCY
AROUND FEES. AND THE NEXUS
STUDIES USED TO JUSTIFY THEM
CAN MAKE DEVELOP RISK MORE
COSTLY AND ALTERNATELY SERVE TO
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF HOUSING
THAT GETS BUILT AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY THREE WILL REQUIRE LOCAL
AGENCIES TO POST ON THEIR
WEBSITES THE TYPE AND AMOUNT OF
EACH BE IMPOSED ON A HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT PROJECT THEIR
CURRENT FIVE PREVIOUS ANNUAL
FEE REPORTS AND ANY APPLICABLE.
NEXUS OR COST OF SERVICE
STUDIES POURTANT CONTROL ADD
MUCH NEEDED TRANSPARENCY AND
CERTAIN TO THE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT APPLICATION PROCESS
I DO HAVE A WITNESS WITH
PERMISSION OF CHAIR TODAY
ANDREW BECAUSE OF OUR WITH.
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS SIR IT'S
GOOD TO SEE BACK IN COMMITTEE
WE ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT CHOOSE
BILL SO IT'S GOOD STUFF IDEA.
HEY IT'S ALL GOOD BUT IT IT'S
GOOD TO SEE MAN THANK YOU SO
MUCH. GREAT TO BE HERE ON A
POSITIVE NOTE. BECAUSE IT OUR
CVA A. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE
IS A BILL THAT WOULD BRING
TRANSPARENCY TO FEES SPECIAL
TAXES AND PROPERTY ASSESSMENTS
ASSOCIATE WITH HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS FOR THIS REASON
THE CBA'S SUPPORT. FOURTEEN
EIGHTY THREE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU FOR COMING TODAY
I WOULD LIKE TO BE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
IF YOU COULD PLEASE COME
FORWARD. FIRST LASSEN
ORGANIZATION GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING THE GOVERNOR THE
CALIFORNIA SET OF REALTORS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
MORNING SO IT'S A MATTER NOT
HAS PUBLIC AFFAIRS HERE ON
BEHALF OF. JEEP OWNERS AS THE
AT HOME AND PH HABITS THE
MINUTE CALIFORNIA IN EAST BAY
SILICON VALLEY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. AB ONE
MORNING CHAMBERS LIST BONTA.
WITH CALIFORNIA. I IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO. GOOD TO SEE. A
LAST CALL A LOT CALL FOR THOSE.
SUPPORT CURRENCY NUMBER NOT A
WELCOME THOSE WHO MAY BE OPPOSE
GONNA WELCOME TO PRIMARY
WITNESSES. ALL RIGHT. GOOD
MORNING WOULD LIKELY TO SEE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO DEDICATE THIS OFF.
RIGHT MORNING THE FIRST US
ORGANIZATIONS GOOD TO SEE BOTH
YOU IN THE MORNING GOOD MORNING
MR MEMBERS JASON RILEY
CALIFORNIA CITIES. WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL UNLESS
IT'S AMENDED I'M A VERY BE
CLEAR WE DO NOT OPPOSE THE
CONTENT OF THE BILL WHATSOEVER
WE ARE SURE SUPPORTIVE OF
PUTTING ALL THIS INFORMATION.
ON OUR WEBSITES THE ISSUE IS
THE BILL'S GOING TAKE EFFECT
JANUARY ONE AND WE WON'T BE
ABLE TO COMPLY WITH THIS BILL
SO WE'RE LEADER TO GET HAVE
HUNDREDS OF CITIES. BREAKING
THE LAW AS OF JANUARY ONE
GRANTED THERE ARE NO FINES OR
PENALTIES IN THIS BILL BUT
THERE'S BEEN A STEADY EFFORT TO
MAKE SURE THIS HE'S ARE
ACCOUNTABLE IT. OLD CITIES
ACCOUNTABLE THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE. I WOULD FIND IN
PANEL I'VE SEEN. REALLY IS GIVE
US THE TIME TO COMPLY. AND WE
WOULD BE HOPE THAT THIS COULD
ACTUALLY YOU KNOW YOU TO BE
DELAYED OR WE CAN HAVE AN
AMENDMENT TO SAVE. YOU KNOW
JULY FIRST OF NEXT YEAR. BUT
THEY THINK THAT WE CAN HAVE ALL
OF THIS INFORMATION. ON OUR
WEBSITES ABOUT TWO MONTHS AS ME
VERY VERY DIFFICULT AND I THINK
THE STUDIES THAT WERE JUST
CITED A MINUTE AGO FOR THE
JUSTIFICATION FOR THE BILL.
ALSO INDICATED THAT THIS
INFORMATION ISN'T NECESSARILY
READY AVAILABLE TONIGHT JUST
LAYING AROUND IT'S GONNA TAKE
TIME AND EFFORT. I'M TO FIND
ALL THAT INFORMATION SO WE JUST
WANNA PATHWAY TO COMPLY SO WHEN
I LOOK AT IT. AT ACTORS THE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. MODESTLY ON
BEHALF OF THE COP. STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES ALSO
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED. AND WE
WERE HOPING TO BE ABLE TO
REMOVE OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
WE'D OFFER TO JULY ONE. I'M
TWENTY TWENTY IMPLEMENTATION
DATE IN OUR OPPOSE LESS AMENDED
MAP LETTER ON AUGUST SIXTEENTH.
UNFORTUNATELY WE SHARE THE
CONCERNS THE LEAGUE ABOUT.
GETTING FOLKS IN COMPLIANCE AND
MAKING SURE THEY'RE AWARE OF
THE LAW. IN THE SHORT
TURNAROUND BETWEEN A SIGNATURE.
IN JANUARY ONE AND FOR THAT
REASON. WE OPPOSE LAST MINUTE.
BUT USUALLY HEY GOOD MORNING
GOOD MORNING CITY GEORGIA
SENDING AMERICAN PLANNING
ASSOCIATION AND WE ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF PREVIOUSLY SAID. WE
SHOULD. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER TO SEE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
ELSE IN. LAST CALL
PROPOSITION. FOR AND BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE ANALYTICALLY
SOME NUMBER ON THIS. IT IS NOT
YOUR INTENT RIGHT I TO BE ABLE
TO ADVANCE IT LIKE THIS AND I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU WANT TO
COMMENT ON THAT AND CLARIFY AND
AT THAT HAVE A MORE COMPLETE
DISMEMBER. ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR OF FIRST OF ALL OF
FOR THE BILL AND THE CONTENT OF
THE BILL TRANSPARENCY IS VERY
VERY IMPORTANT AS FAR AS MAKING
SURE THE DEVELOPERS ARE FULLY
AWARE UP FRONT WHAT THE FEES
ARE GOING TO BE BECAUSE IT IS
TRULY. IMPACTFUL TO DEVELOPMENT
TO GET THE PROCESS OR ACTUALLY
THE PROCESS AND STILL GET TO
THE ALMOST THE CLOTHES AND FIND
OUT THERE'S ADDITIONAL FEES
THAT WERE DISCLOSED AT THE
BEGINNING. HAVING SAID THAT
THERE ARE A THREE MONTHS
BETWEEN NOW AND THE END OF THE
YEAR IN WHICH CITIES CAN BEGIN
TO COMPLY IF NOT ALREADY THE
INFORMATION IS ALREADY THERE
IT'S AVAILABLE IT'S JUST.
PUTTING IT ALL TOGETHER AND
PLACING IT ON THE WEBSITE WHICH
IS NOT. A DIFFICULT HOWEVER
APPROPRIATIONS DID YOU GET OUT
THE ENFORCED MECHANISM SO THERE
IS NO ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM TO
THIS TO THIS BILL OUTSIDE OF
JUST REQUIRING THE CITY'S POST
THEIR FREEZE ON THEIR WEBSITE.
AND FOR THE MORE I AM FULLY
WHEN HER PERCENT COMMITTED AS
YOU OF ALL STATED WITH SEVERAL
OTHER BILLS THAT ARE IN THE
WORKS AS FAR AS COMING UP IN
JANUARY FULLY WILLING TO SIT
DOWN AND WORK WITH IN THE
INTERIM SO THAT WE CAN MEET LEE
ADDRESS EVER ISSUES. THIS IS
MAY BE FACING ON JANUARY FIRST
WEEK IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
LEAGUE OF CITIES BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS THOSE IMMEDIATELY AND
GET SOMETHING ACROSS THAT CAN
PROVIDE WHATEVER PRESSURE
RELIEF IS AVAILABLE. YEAH I
KNOW I AND I APPRECIATE IT LOOK
I THINK THAT I'M. MOST OF US
ARE GOING TO BE AN AGREEMENT
THAT WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO POST
AYE AYE HERE. LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
SAYING THE SAME THING
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS EVEN
SAY THIS BUT NO STICK IN
REGARDS TO THE FIND FEES RIGHT.
AND I THINK THAT YOU'RE
COMMITTED. IN OUR PUT WORDS IN
YOUR MOUTH BUT IF WE NEED TO BE
A LOOK AT SOME TYPE OF. DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION TO BE A TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE. EVERYONE ON
BOARD I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT I KNOW WE'D LIKE TO SEE I
DON'T SPEAK FOR THE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN. A CHAIR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
BUT I DON'T THINK THAT WILL BE
SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE
DIFFICULT TO BE A TO WORK
THROUGH ABSOLUTELY AND I THINK
WE OF. THE SHUTTLE NUMBER AND
THAT WE'RE VERY WORKABLE AS AS
IT TOO. OFTEN ON BOTH SIDES
ASSEMBLY AND SENATE. AS WELL AS
MY OFFICE AND THEN AND WE CAN
TALK ABOUT THIS AFTER ME WE CAN
JUST SEND A QUICK LETTER TO
SAYING THAT. THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WERE COMMITTEE DEBATE A
LOOK AT I IN REGARDS THAT
DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION. SUPPORT
OF THE BILL TODAY OBVIOUSLY AS
I SAID TO THIS SOME. BUT. I
THINK THAT'S SOMETHING THAT IS
JUST. IT THE LOW HANGING PIECE
OF FRUIT. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN. WANNA THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD I WILL. SO EXPRESS MY
DISAPPOINTMENT ABOUT THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE FORCED
INTO THE BILL IN THE
APPROPRIATIONS PROCESS I WANNA
JUST REPEAT WHAT I'VE SAID
BEFORE MIGHT CONTINUING
OBJECTION TO. WHAT HAPPENS IN
THIS LEGISLATURE WHERE POLICY
COMMITTEES THOROUGHLY BAT BILLS
AND CRAFT AND I SPEND A LOT OF
TIME WORKING TOGETHER AND- I
OFTEN BECAUSE OF THE TWO
COMMITTEES WHICH ARE WORK
TOGETHER. ON BILLS TOGETHER AND
THEN WITH REALLY NO
TRANSPARENCY POLICY CHANGES
SIGNIFICANT ONES. ARE SHOVED
INTO A BILL IN THE
APPROPRIATIONS PROCESS WITH NO
POLICY ANALYSIS WITH NO
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS ON WHICH
THE TOP AND WITH NUMEROUS
HOUSING BILLS THIS YEAR. AND I
JUST DON'T THINK IT'S A CREEK
I'M A MEMBER THE LEGISLATURE WE
ALL WENT TO THE STRUCTURE THAT
EXISTS BUT IT'S NOT A GOOD
STRUCTURE AND IT HAPPENED HERE.
IT IS A ROOM STILL IS A GOOD
BILL. BUT IT WAS AN EVEN BETTER
BILL THAT REALLY. HELP WELL
UNDERSTANDING OF THE DATA THAT
WE NEED. SOLVE THIS ARE CRISIS
AND I JUST HOPE THAT WE CAN I
HOPE THAT WE CAN MAKE SOME
CHANGES AND I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY. THANK
YOU SO MUCH RESEARCH AREA I
KNOW I THINK THAT YOU YOU TO ME
ON THE HEAD OF. HOW WE WORK
TOGETHER IN OUT WELL I TO BE
ABLE TO CRESCENT SOLUTIONS I
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT AS WELL
AND THAT THERE'S MORE TO COME
HERE. I'M COMING UP IN TWENTY
TWENTY SO AND GRATEFUL FOR THE
COLLABORATION. PLEASE
DISCUSSION ABOUT. YOU KNOW I
LOOK THE DECISIVE IN A REAL
DIFFICULT THING TO COME OUT.
PERSONALLY I THINK. CITIES
ALREADY DO THE SONG. THE THEY
DO OF FEEL ARE NECESSARY. IF
YOUR ASHES THE DESCRIBES WHAT
THE FEES FOR ALL THE
INFORMATION YOU HAVE IN YOUR
BILL SO I THINK COULD BE PRETTY
EASY TO IMPLEMENT THANKED OF.
MAKING IT MORE TRANSPARENT IS A
GOOD THING AND WE RECENTLY GOT
THE REPORT FROM EACH CD AND I
READ THE REPORT ON ON FEES
THANK YOU FOR OFFERING THE BILL
THAT CREATED THAT REPORT AND-
I'M SURE THE NEXTYEAR WE'RE
GOING TO DO A LOT OF THINGS TO
IMPLEMENT. IN THAT REPORT
CORRECT IS THAT. WORKING ON YOU
KNOW FOR THE FUTURE I THINK
THERE'S SOMETHING SAY. THE
DIVIDE THAT WE NEED TO WORK ON.
AND WE'LL TAKE A LOOK AT THAT
NEXT YEAR AND KEEP WORKING ON
IT. SO EVERYBODY SHOULD READ
THE REPORT ON THE FEES AT. JUST
CAME OUT IT'S- VERY INTERESTING
HAS WATER GOOD RECOMMENDATIONS.
THE CENTRE BELL IS DONE A DEEP
DIVE ON THAT AND VERY GRATEFUL
AS WELL UP FOR HIS WORK I
INCLUDING US IN A MEETING WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF THANK YOU SO
MUCH ABOUT FOR. YOUR WORK ON
THAT BECAUSE I KNOW IT'S- VERY
PERSONAL FOR YOU. RECEIVE ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COM.
PLEASE MAJORITY LEADER. I LOVE
THE ART OF THIS BILL HE'S A
DEAR FRIEND. BUT MY AGE IN THIS
HOUSE IS TO REPRESENT THE
INSTITUTION. TO ME IT'S GOTTEN
A MEN'S THERE'S AN IMPORTANT
ASPECT OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PROCESS. WE ARE IN THE LAST FEW
HOURS OF THIS LEGISLATURE
THEY'RE OFTEN REASONS FOR
EXAMPLE WITH THE GERMANS
WORKING ON A MATTER THAT'S BEEN
PENDING FOR MONTHS AND IT TOOK
AWHILE TO GET A DEAL TOGETHER
AS WE KNOW. IT WOULD THAT
OURSELVES TOGETHER. AND THE
QUESTION I HAVE IS WHAT'S THE
COMPELLING REASON WHY IS THIS
LEGISLATURE AT THIS TIME WHY
THIS LATE WHAT HAPPENED. IS
FROM THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
I'M ASKING THE TOUGH QUESTIONS
TO A DEAR FRIEND OF MY PARTY IS
MANNERS NOT. THAT WE NOW HAVE
TO HEAR THIS BILL NOW WE ALL
IT'S LIKE WHEN YOU GO IN FOR
INJUNCTIVE RELIEF YOU HAVE TO
MAKE A SHOWING OF IRREPARABLE
INJURY. YOU HAVE TO MAKE SOME
URGENCY WHAT'S THE URGENCY IT
DOESN'T ALLOW THIS THING TO GO
FORWARD IN NEXT LEGISLATIVE
SESSION OR MORE IMPORTANTLY WHY
ARE YOU COMING TO A NOW DID YOU
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO. AND
JUST ALL OF A SUDDEN SOMEBODY
COMES TO YOU IN JUST MY GOD WE
GET THESE ALL MY GUYS ALL THE
TIME SO I JUST. IN PROTECTING
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS THAT MAKES
ENEMIES. I MEAN EVERYBODY GETS
PISSED AT ME FOR ASKING THE
QUESTIONS BUT I THINK. YOU KNOW
AS THE DEAN OVER HERE US TO ALL
DOGS IN TIS PLACE WE HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO PROTECT THE
INTEGRITY OF THIS INSTITUTION.
THE NUMBER WOULD CHECK THAT.
COMMENT ABSOLUTELY. BACK TO A
VERY DEAR FRIEND OF MINE
THROUGH THE CHAIR PLEASE PLEASE
THIS THIS BILL WAS ACTUALLY GOT
IT IN A PROBES AND WE'RE TRYING
TO PUT ME BACK INTO IT. WE'RE
TRYING TO PUT THE SUBSTANCE
BACK INTO IT THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING NEW IN NO UP TO ME
AWAKENED ME IN THE MIDDLE HI
THIS IS BEEN A LONGSTANDING
PIECE OF WORK AND PARTNERSHIP.
BETWEEN THE CHAIRS AND MYSELF
AS THE AUTHOR AND THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT HAS BEEN A TOPIC
AND ACTUALLY A PRODUCT OF AB
EIGHT SEVEN NINE WHICH WAS A
BILL THAT WAS SIGNED INTO LAW
BY GOVERNOR BROWN IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. REPORT WHAT
DO JUNE THIRTIETH AND
UNFORTUNATELY THAT REPORT WAS
HELD THE RESULTS OF THAT REPORT
WERE HELD FOR A WHILE AND AS
SOON AS WE RECEIVE THE REPORT
WHAT WE DID WAS. MUCH
COLLABORATION WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE DECIDED TO PICK THE
MOST BOB IT'S AND THE EASIEST
TO IMPLEMENT AND PUT THAT IN
INTO THIS BILL AND TO PUT
SUBSTANCE INTO A BILL THAT WAS
ALREADY MOVING FORWARD
SOMETHING THAT'S NOT A NEW
DISCUSSION SOMETHING THAT'S NOT
A SURPRISE TO ANYBODY. BUT
SOMETHING THAT LEAVE EVERYONE
IF THEY DIDN'T THEY SURE
EXPECTED THIS KIND OF
TRANSPARENCY AND JUST PRINT YOU
SHOULD HAVE ALREADY BEEN SOME
OF THE IN THE FIRST PLACE SO
WE'RE WE'RE LOOKING. FORWARD TO
MOVING SOMETHING FORWARD. THAT
IS. HEAVY MEET AND- WILL SAVE
THAT FOR FOURTEEN EIGHTY FOR
NEXT YEAR THANK YOU MOVE THE
BILL. COULD ANSWER. THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER MATURE LATER WE
DO HAVE A MOTION. NO NO THIS
GOOD AT MATURITY DATE. NO
LONGER YOU YOU MADE THE MOTION
TO WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
FLOOR WHICH IS TO TURN THE BILL
TO THE SENATE FLOOR SOME NUMBER
IT IS WHEN I GO BACK TO THE-
THE DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION
BECAUSE I THINK THERE WAS A
INTENT TO BE A LOOK AT SOME
DELAYED IMPLANTATION
ORIGINALLY. I JUST WANNA GET
YOUR TAKE AND I DON'T MEAN TO
DO THIS ON THE FLY WITH UNITED
PRE SHEET YOUR PATIENTS EITHER
WE- DO A LETTER TOGETHER AND
SEND IT OUT TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
GROUPS OR YOU DO A LOT OF THE
JOURNAL. ABOUT ENFORCEMENT
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK IT WAS
YOUR INTENTION NOT TO HAVE THAT
DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION LANGUAGE
IN THE BILL HOW WOULD YOU LIKE
TO GO TO PROCEED WITH THAT AND
I DO BETTER DO ONE OR TWO. RUSH
TO DO IT TOGETHER OKAY. IT'S
AND I'M VERY VERY COME. TO BEEN
WONDERFUL TO WORK WITH. THAT'S
GREAT. SO AGAIN. IS A MEMBER
HAS BEEN MORE THAN
COLLABORATIVE. ON THIS ISSUE
AND SO. WILL WORK OUT. I
UNDERSTAND THAT IS NOT WHAT
YOU'RE WANTING HERE TODAY. I
ALSO KNOW THAT WON'T REMOVE THE
OPPOSITION. BUT I. RIGHT THE
INTENT IS TO BE A LOOK AT THAT
DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION. AND I
THINK THAT THERE IS SOME.
SECURITY IN THAT THERE IS NO
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM. SO
UNDERSTAND OTHER. AGAINST
BEFORE WE TURN OVER THE SUMMER
FOR FINAL COMMENTS. ALTERN OF
THE OPPOSITION. FOR ANY COMMENT
THAT YOU HAVE ON THAT. GIVE ME
THE ADDRESS AROUND THE
CALIFORNIA CITIES CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE LETTER I THINK
IT IT'S CERTAINLY BE HELPFUL.
BUT YOU HAVE TO GO BACK TO WHAT
THE A CENTER HERTZBERG SAID IN
HIS COMMENTS ABOUT WHAT IS THE
RUSH. FOR NOT ENOUGH THERE'S NO
ENFORCEMENT HERE IF THERE'S NO
HAMMER THAN REALLY WHAT'S THE
RUSSIAN MAYBE WE COULD DO THIS
NEXT YEAR BUT- CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE EFFORT HERE IN
AND WILL. WILL WILL LOOK FOR
THAT LETTER. YEAH I MEAN I. BE
VERY CANDID. YOU REGIONAL
THOUGHT WAS ODD THAT. THEY
SHOULD NOT MOVING THEIR ST WHY
IS THAT RIGHT BUT ANYWAY. SO
WELL TO SAY THAT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE START MOVING
ON THIS THERE'S A REPORT. AND
THAT WE START GRAVITATING
TOWARDS. A PUTTING THESE FEES
ONLINE SO I THINK. HE'S BEEN
THE ONE THING I WILL SAY. IS
THAT WE- WE HAD WHAT WAS A
CONFERENCE CALL WE COULD GO. A
AND AGREED TO BE ABLE TO MOVE
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE FORWARD. I
THINK IT'S GONNA BE IMPORTANT
FOR THE PUBLIC AND THOSE WHO
ARE DOING BUSINESS WITH LOCAL
CITIES AND COUNTIES. I'M AND
THIS IS HIS INTENT TO BE ABLE
TO START MOVING THIS ISSUE. AND
THEN COMING UP NEXT YEAR WE'LL
SEE. AT THE EXTENT OF THE BILL
SO BE ADVANCE. I HEAR YOU'RE
SAYING AND AGAIN VERY GRATEFUL
FOR YOUR- COLLABORATION AS WELL
AS WELL AS YOUR ADVOCACY.
CENTER. I'M SORRY WAS IN A SEMI
BUT I MEAN. FIRST OF ALL AND I
DON'T. I DON'T ON THE PHONE FOR
ME ABOUT WHO IS OPPOSING THIS
BILL AND APPROPRIATIONS I'M
GOING TO SPECULATE. THAT THE
SAME POINTS TODAY WERE PROBABLY
OF. POSING AS AN APPROPRIATIONS.
YEAH I DON'T THOSE ARE GOING
PROVISIONS I THINK WE HAD A
COALITION THAT ARE FOUND IN IT
BUT TO BE CLEAR WE ARE NOT
OPPOSED TO ON TO THE MEASURE IN
ANYWAY I UNDERSTAND YOUR
SUPPORTIVE OF BUT I. I'M I'M
JUST GUESSING THAT BOTTOM FOR
SOME PEACE ONE OF THE REASONS
THAT CAME OUT WAS BECAUSE THERE
WAS PUSHED BACK. FROM FROM
CITIES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND WE
DON'T WANT TO FORCE MEANT WE
DON'T WANT DO NOT WE DO NOT WE
AGREED TO THE ACTUAL X. THE
EXPANDED APR PROVISIONS IN THE
BILL AS AMENDED SO WE REQUESTED
THREE AMENDMENTS. ONE WAS ABOUT
THAT POPULATION THRESHOLD AFTER
WHICH THE EXPANDED APR WOULD
APPLY ONE WAS ABOUT THE
REFERENCE TO THIS FEE PIECE
WE'RE TALKING TO HOW YOU REPORT
THAT IN THE APR. IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION DATE FOR WHEN
YOU NEED TO PUT THAT ON THE
WEBSITE. IT WAS OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE HAD
REACHED AN AGREEMENT THAT THE
IMPLEMENTATION DATE FOR THAT
PARTICULAR MOMENT WOULD BE.
JULY ONE TWENTY TWENTY BASED ON
A CONVERSATION ON. BEFORE.
APPROPRIATIONS IN IN LATE
AUGUST AND SO. I APPRECIATE
THAT BUT WE WERE WILLING TO GO
ACTUALLY MUCH FURTHER ON THE
REPORTING PIECE I THINK THE
AUTHOR WILL BOLSTER THAT
ARGUMENT. YEAH I APPRECIATE
DIED ON IN FROM CANNOT. AND SO
WHAT'S THERE I JUST DON'T AGREE
WITH THAT I KNOW YOU'RE GOING
TO THE YOUR FOLKS WILL DO THE
BEST THEY CAN AND- AND THE
SOONER THE BETTER I DO JUST
WANT TO SAY IN TERMS OF WHAT'S
THE RUSH. IN TERMS OF WHY IS
THIS THE KIND OF MAN I MEAN
LIKE. CHILDREN ARE SLEEPING IN
THEIR CARS RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
JUST A AT THE THIS IS A BAD
SITUATION THAT WE HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA I'M NOT TRYING TO BE
MELODRAMATIC IT IS A BAD. BAD
SITUATION AND THERE IS HUMAN
SUFFERING THROUGHOUT THE STATE
BECAUSE OUR FAILURE ON HOUSING
AND SO IT IS A VERY URGENT
SITUATION AND I DON'T THINK
IT'S A SITUATION WE'RE GONNA SO
LET'S WAIT TILL NEXT YEAR AND I
THINK THIS PIECE. ACTUALLY
HAVING TRANSPARENCY SO WE SEE
THE DATA AROUND THESE FEES
BECAUSE WHEN WE KNOW THAT THERE
ARE SIGNIFICANT DISPARITIES IN
THIS IS IMPORTANT INFORMATION
SO THERE IS A BIG RUSH THANK
YOU THE STATE SENATOR AND YES
SAID YOU HAVE N. COLLABORATIVE
DO APPRECIATE THAT AND I. DON'T
WANT TO SPEAK FOR THE SUMMER
THE LAST TIME I SAY THAT TODAY
BUT I THINK IT IT WAS
INADVERTENT IN REGARDS TO THE
REMOVAL OF THAT TIME LINE SO IT
WAS AN INTENTIONAL BUT IT WAS.
AN IMPORTANT ON THE FEE I THINK
IN THE MINUTE PROCESS PREVIOUS
COMMITTEE CELL BUT I'LL LET THE
SOME CLOTHES. THANK YOU LOOK
FOR TO WORK WITH AND WE'LL WORK
ON THAT LETTER TOGETHER IS WELL
PLEASE MR SUMMER THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I HAVE
IMMENSE RESPECT THE
INSTITUTION. I HAVE VERY HIGH
REGARD FOR THE LEAGUE OF CITIES
AND THE GREAT WORK THAT THEY DO
IN REPRESENTING OUR CITIES.
THANK YOU TO THE SENATOR IN THE
BAY OR THE COMMENTS THAT YOU
HAVE MADE. SPECIALLY IN
RECOGNITION OF THE HOUSE I SAYS.
THAT WE ARE FACING. IT'S EASY.
TO HOUSING CRISIS. WE HAVE WE
HAVE GOT TO DO SOMETHING AND
QUIT PUTTING THE STARTING LINE
OUT INTO THE FUTURE. WE'VE GOT
A START AND WE GOT A STAR NOW
WE'VE WE FELT LIKE WE FOUND.
THE EASIEST THING TO START
WITH. AND THIS WILL BE A
CONTINUING WORK I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU SO MUCH
SIR WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
FLOOR BY THE MAJORITY LEADER
THEIR MOTION IS RETURN THE BILL
TO THE SENATE FLOOR MISS
LANCHESTER CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. HI YEAH. I HERTZBERG.
REGARD RICARDO. HELLO I
NIELSEN. GIPSON AYE WIENER
WIENER HI. THE CURRENT ADDRESS
A SIX YEAR VOTE AT WE'RE GOING
TO KEEP THAT OF THE AND I'M
SORRY YOU'RE RIGHT THAT BILL IS
OUT RECALLS THE ROLE. THEY SING
GERMAN THANK YOU SO MUCH VERY
GRATEFUL MRS AMERICA TO SEE YOU
WE'RE GONNA ADD TO THE MAJORITY
LEADER ON TO OUR FOUST FIRST
TWO ITEMS BUT FOR THE FIRST
TIME EVER BEFORE WE LEAVE WE
HAVE A VERY SPECIAL RECOGNITION
FOR THE VICE CHAIR. AND MISS
FURTADO. YOURS IN HIS ABSENCE.
I WOULD YOU MIND GIVING IT TO
THE MAJORITY LEADER. AS
MAJORITY LEADER BY FAR AS
RECEIVE MORE WORDS IN ANYONE
COMBINED ON THIS COMMITTEE. I
THAT HE COULD THEN PASSED ON
THAT AWARD TO THE VICE CHAIR AT
CENTER TITLE THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
AND FOR MOST AND TODAY HAVE THE
HONOR OF PRESENTING THE RICARDO
LARA WORK TO OUR MAJORITY
LEADER WHO WILL. MOVE
MORTARBOARD. MORE MORE TO HAVE
BEEN HERE AT ALL NO FOR THE
FIRST TIME EVER FOR THE FIRST
TIME EVER IT'S ONE THING TO WIN
THE AWARD FOR BEING LATE HI.
IT'S A NEW AWARD FOR NOT
SHOWING UP I DON'T KNOW I WE
GOT TO DO THAT I THINK WE HAVE
TO HAVE A SUBCOMMITTEE OF THIS
THE STEAM COMMITTEE THAT WILL
THEN DECIDE WHO WERE GONNA GET
NAME FOR THAT NEW AWARD FOR NOT
SHOWING UP. WHAT DO YOU THINK
ABOUT THAT CENTER BELL I THINK
IT'S WHAT WE SHOULD DO. WHO AND
I TRIED TO THAT ONE. RIGHT SO
IT ANY OF IT YOU KNOW IS THE-
RECIPIENT OF THIS AWARD ALL I
CAN TELL YOU IS. IN EACH
INSTANCE IT IS NOT FOR. FONG
SEND RESPECT FOR THE GOOD WORK
OF. THIS COMMITTEE IN THE PEAK
MEMBERS. ON IT. IT IS BECAUSE I
HAVE BEEN OTHERWISE EMPLOYED
AND DOING OTHER. DUTIES
RELATING TO MY JOB SO WITH
THAT. I WILL PASS ON THE
TEMPORARILY NAMED RICARDO LARA
WARD TO THE- IN ABSENTIA. TO
THE VICE CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE WITH THE- CONDITION
THAT WE ARE GOING TO COME BACK
AND RE NAME IT. IN SOME NEW
BETTER FASHION FOR THE FELLA.
OR MEMBER THAT DOES NOT SHOW UP.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A MAJORITY
LEADER LACING GERMAN AGAIN WE
WILL PROBABLY HAVE AT LEAST ONE
MORE COMMITTEE FOR SURE. IT
SOMETIME THIS WEEK AND WE MAY
HAVE TO SO JUST A HEADS UP ON
THAT. TO LISTEN CHEN WE HAVE
TWO BILLS THAT WE'RE GONNA ADD
THE MAJORITY LEADER ON TO
EVERYONE ELSE I THINK IS LET
ME. JUST GIVE US THIRTY SECONDS
ME SEE WHO ELSE WE NEED TO ADD
ON ONE SECOND. THE ONLY ONE THE
TWO MEMBERS THAT WE'RE GONNA
NEED TO ADD ON IS MISS FURTADO
IN MISTER HERTZBERG. OTHERWISE
YOU ARE MORE THAN WELCOME TO
ENJOY THE COFFEE AND A
STARBURST AND HANG OUT WITH
THAT SO LAZY CHEN WE'RE GONNA
ADD ON WE'RE GONNA START WITH
ITEM NUMBER ONE THIS IS AB
SEVEN TWENTY THREE. THE MOTION
IS RETURN THE BILL TO THE
SENATE FLOOR THE CURRENT VOTE
IS THREE ONE. THANK YOU SIR CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. HERTZBERG I HER TOTAL.
WE HAVE. FOUR FOUR ONE FIVE
FORTY FOUR. HE SAID NO YEAH.
FOUR TWO FOUR TWO THAT BILL IS
OUT AND WE'RE CLOSED THE ROLE
THIS IS OUR LAST ITEM THAT
WE'RE GONNA ADD FOLKS ON TO
ITEM NUMBER TO AB SEVEN FIFTY
FOR THE MOTION IS RETURN THE
BILL TO THE SENATE FLOOR THE
CURRENT VOTE. IS FOUR ZERO MISS
LANCASTER. BURKE ALL RIGHT SIX.
THAT BILL IS OUT ON A SIX ZERO
VOTE WE'RE NOW CLOSED IN THE
ROLE LAYS IN GERMAN WE WILL SEE
YOU LATER THIS WEEK THANK YOU
ALL FOR BEING HERE. THIS
MEETING IS ADJOURNED